[Music]
[Music]
okay got eyes on the bar
yep
here he comes
and i got the dealer
nino they're heading your way
[Applause]
they're here you should have eyes on the
merchandise i sure do
[Music]
was that a gunshot
ah they shot the dealer
that is so unprofessional
there's a lot
can we do this we can't afford not to
nina you good yeah let's do it great
whenever you're ready kevin what are you
guys thinking for dinner
chili tonight carne
[Music]
hey guys
what you got in the
oh stolen marshall mdi-101 m9
multi-rocket shoulder launchers nice
my buddies and i have been looking all
over town from us have you been hoarding
see we need them for our startup it's a
criminal empire
[Music]
one two three
[Music]
um
[Music]
you should buckle up
[Music]
kevin
[Music]
get the [ __ ] away from my friends
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
why are you here
to fight
to win
to be a spartan
what is a spartan
[Music]
a spartan is a symbol
hope
where there is none
in times of darkness
we are hopeful
[Music]
and together
[Music]
together we are unstoppable
[Music]
candidates are you ready yes ma'am i
can't hear you
again
who's first
[Music]
[Music]
miss tilly
i'm afraid i only have a few minutes
let's get right to it
yesterday your network yarovision was
hijacked by rebels
don't shoot
they called for the liberation of
so-called outcasts from the vero labor
camps is vivero produced with slave
labor
saves millions of lives do you think
that those lives care where it comes
from you were imprisoned at the age of
13 the same age as diego you spend a lot
of time with your father
he is a great teacher a lion finds calm
before the queue
fire me
i understand you were forced to endure
15 years of hard labor pruning tobacco i
hear you still have the blade
when yara becomes paradise
my methods
no one will care
you are the only survivor i watched
castillo order a whole boat of our
people shot to death
get as far away as you can from that
psychopath all of you
a revolution is not won by the fearless
is won by the fear
to libertad danny
i have a vision to rebuild paradise
a cure
viviro the most effective treatment for
cancer the world has ever seen grown
within our precious tobacco but our
paradise comes at a cost this our
enemies will never understand out
now your safety's on
you want me to kill anton castillo
kill a dictator who has raped our land
and turned our people into slaves
thinking about it
what about you
you're gonna be a hungarian legend
i'm not fearless
but i promise you one thing
i will be here
there are lions there are lamps
and we eat the flames
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
there are now new items that allow for
easier and safe delivery
one of the new items is the evolve
stabilizers which features thrusters
that help reduce the impact of landing
when jumping from higher areas
the cargo catapult is a cannon-like
device that can launch your cargo over
long distances
enabling you to develop even more
creative ways to deliver your cargo
safely and more efficiently
you should have more faith in yourself
your trusted partner the bodybot has
increased capabilities also
[Applause]
if you want to move around comfortably
while carrying more cargo you can rely
on bodybot to assist you
load up what you want to deliver and
leave the cargo carrying to your buddy
you can relax and think about what you
need for the next delivery
yeah like that
[Music]
the firing range has been set up in the
basement of the facilities
practicing how to handle your weapons
could level up your delivery skill set
you can also train and compete for the
highest score
[Applause]
as you progress through the game
you'll also be able to unlock new
missions and weapons
the mazer gun is one of the new weapons
that will be introduced it has a few
different functions it can inflict
sustained stun damage to enemies
boss battles can now be revisited and
fought as many times as you like via
your private room
your scores will be shared in the
all-new online ranking system
allowing you to compete with players
from around the globe
eight new tracks have been added in the
music player
you can listen to the tracks in the
private room
it will help you and sam really
so
so
new action-packed delivery missions have
been added
[Music]
uh
what truth will sam unfold in the
mysterious facility
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
we've also added jump ramps enabling you
to jump over valleys and crevices with
these
you can even do tricks
[Music]
there is a new race track you can time
attack with other sam players from all
around the world who are connected
online in the rankings
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the stories you've heard
they don't tell
the all truth
the island is indeed a place of legend
there is power
and vast riches as well
[Music]
but many who've sought to claim them
have simply
vanished without a
[Music]
trace your ship is stocked and your crew
assembled
[Music]
charge your course and your fate
we can pretend
no longer
this corruption must be done
[Music]
i will say a prayer for the souls of
your crew
i am
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
i can't help myself
[Music]
go
[Music]
promise promise me you will train the
boy
yes master
i was once a jedi knight
the same as your father
how did my father die
ready are you what know you have ready
the rebellion is reborn today
the war is just beginning
and i will not be the last jedi
[Music]
reach out
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
the boy has no patience
he is not ready i am ready i
ben i i could be a jedi ben tell him i'm
rich
[Music]
the pages of history are filled with
moments that determine an empire's fate
every decision can be the difference
between rising to power or being lost to
history
how will you grow a small fort
into a mighty empire
every empire no matter how large came
from humble beginnings
some invested in advancing technology to
create the most powerful armies
how will you use your resources to rise
above the rest
is
aloy here
if i have to share something it'll be my
bow
in the service of people who need the
help
[Music]
[Music]
you're stuck now
[Applause]
the hunt is on
you